welcome back the deadline for choosing
an individual or family health plan is
fast approaching here to tell us more is
Anna landros the Nevada manager of
individual products for Select Health in
Nevada who are also sponsoring this
segment welcome to the show thank you
thank you for having us let's start with
those important dates break down those
dates for everyone watching right now so
open enrollment started November 1st it
does go through January 15th okay
however if we want to start coverage
January 1st we do want to make sure we
have our applications in by December
31st okay we've been locked in there by
the end of the year now if we happen to
miss that deadline we have a little
question there gives us till January
15th to start coverage February so
there's a little wiggle room but you
don't want to wait for that wiggle we
want to get the things done now
absolutely yes December 31st let's get
it in so let's talk about some of the
new things in 2023 what should we be
aware of going into the new year so 2023
first thing I would recommend is make
sure we check if we're eligible for a
government subsidy okay also known as an
advanced premium tax credit this is
based off of your income and can make
your premium very affordable
is that one of the ways you can save
money going into the news it seems like
everything the cost of everything is
going up but you have ways to save money
when it comes to this how can we do that
so we do have our Wellness reward
benefit so this actually puts money back
into your pocket
um so just some to look into how does
that work because I like I like the
sound that we say putting money back in
our pocket how does that work so this is
based keeping you healthy okay so if
you're going to the gym you log into
your member account we give you twenty
dollars a month it does it's 240 dollars
per
year per member or 540 for the family
it's just available to you in the form
of a gift card okay put some money back
in your pocket yeah I love that I bet
you everyone watching loves the sound of
that as well there are so many different
plans out there and so many little
nuances with each plan how do we find
the right one to fit our needs there's
different plan options as you know um so
my best suggestion is contact an agent
okay or give us a call at Select Health
everybody has different situations
different needs so there's not a one
plan fits all for everybody Arizona does
have questions you guys have the answers
don't be afraid to call don't be afraid
to ask right exactly and let's let's hit
those dates one more time because I
think that's so important break down the
dates we want to apply by December 31st
for January 1st effective date okay
um if you happen to miss that which
please don't but if you do and forget
about your New Year's plans let's get
this done first insurance is priority
that is big time yeah priority yes I
love it but January 15th is for February
first effective okay so we want to get
done locked in by the end of the year
absolutely Anna thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate unit and for
more information give them a call at
1-855-442-0220 or visit their website at
selectthealth.org and Las Vegas now we
will be right back